[Music]
human-to-animal shape-shifting creatures
are a worldwide phenomenon where
predatory beasts exist in a myriad of
forms where hyenas wear tigers wear
panthers wear jaguars but the werewolf
is the most notorious of them all
there's so much history behind the
infamous shapeshifters that were going
to take two episodes to trace the
beginnings of the werewolf in europe
through their entrance into modern
literature and pop culture the first
thing to understand about the history of
the werewolf is that there is no single
origin legend of these lupine
shapeshifters are so numerous and
widespread their pervasiveness makes
identifying one universal definition or
origin of the wolf human monster
challenging despite the werewolves
widespread appearance in folklore i'll
admit i haven't really given the
werewolf the attention it deserves until
now
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
the wolf has symbolized everything from
an admirable patron of warriors to
figures for greed and even as the devil
in disguise these near silent deadly
predators were at one point the most
widely distributed land mammal claiming
large swaths of the globe as their
hunting grounds and wolves posed a very
real threat to humans and their
livestock
still we seem to have admired the
animals our ancestors donned the skins
of predators while hunting perhaps to
camouflage themselves or to evoke the
spirit of an animal during the hunt as
archaeological artifacts and ancient art
reveal humans and wolves existed as both
allies and enemies while some wolves
were eventually domesticated for hunting
and protection their wild brethren
remained a threat these early
connections set the stage for a complex
relationship between man wolf and wear
hybrid
but does that mean werewolves were
originally a universal monster were
there other factors that came into play
to understand the origins of werewolves
more clearly i reached out to dr kaya
frank werewolf expert and visiting
professor at the university of
hertfordshire
wolves themselves exist in many
different countries and in many
different continents and because of this
they have become powerful symbols of the
animal other
wolves and their behavior
is often very similar to how humans
exist they live in families and they
hunt as pacs and they predate on the
same creatures that we'd like to eat
ourselves and so it makes sense that
folklore would absorb these creatures
and they would recur in myths and in
legends and humoured would see them as
existing on the boundaries of what it
was to be human and what it was to be
animal
the connections between wolves and
humans are deeply ingrained in ancient
literature and lore
these early stories seem to categorize
werewolves into three different types
the victim where an innocent person is
cursed to turn into a wolf but maintains
human reason
the damned who are violent humans that
become wolves as a punishment to both
their body and soul
and the warrior where humans take on the
guise of the wolf to aid in success in
battle the oldest piece of surviving
literature we know about the epic of
gilgamesh portrays a victim werewolf in
what is widely considered the oldest
werewolf story on record written between
1300 and 1000 bce it tells of an unlucky
shepherd whom the goddess inanna turns
into a wolf in contrast werewolves of
ancient greece and roman mythology are
dominantly portrayed as the damned
werewolf representing a tradition of
human-to-wolf transformations
distinguished by deviant deeds in the
greek text agriopas olympionics a man is
turned into a wolf for 10 years as
punishment for eating human entrails
cannibalism is a recurring theme in
ancient myths that use wolf
transformation as a cautionary tale
linking human cannibalism to wolves
isn't that far-fetched wolves are above
all opportunistic eaters in addition to
scavenging animal corpses of all kinds
including humans wolves have been known
to eat the remains of their own species
in the first century ce pliny wrote
naturalis historia associating human
cannibalism with wolf-like behavior and
features about 8ce of its mortal
morphosis interprets another greek
legend about the god zeus and king
lakayan of arcadia according to the
story the roman god jupiter hears rumors
that king lachaon is practicing human
sacrifice and cannibalism so he descends
to earth in human form to discover the
truth
like keon is unconvinced of jupiter's
divinity and decides to put his
omniscience to the test
he kills butchers and attempts to serve
human flesh to the god jupiter is
appalled by the crime and the deception
so he destroys the king's household in a
mad rage a distraught like heyon takes
to the fields howling
driven mad by his own misdeeds he begins
to slaughter the flocks as a horrible
transformation takes place his clothes
become hair his arms turn to legs and he
transforms fully into a wolf although
his human eyes remain
if the name lacan sounds familiar your
wolf sense might be tingling the greek
word lycos meaning wolf and anthropos
meaning man inspired the word
lycanthropy or wolf man syndrome
the word was invented in the early 2nd
century by greek physician marcellus to
define a melancholy affliction
identified by the habit of frequenting
cemeteries and behaving like wolves and
dogs the third ancient werewolf trope
the warrior is perhaps most famously
associated with berserkers ancient
nordic fighters who took on a predatory
animal's characteristics in battle
bears wolves and boars were revered by
berserkers and it was believed that
literally donning the skin of an animal
allowed a transformation to occur
they would fight with crazed seemingly
preternatural violence howling and
roaring on the battlefield instead of
separating humans from beasts this
concept respects both in tandem
however psychological and physical
shape-shifting were seen as different
concepts the berserker took on the
spirit of the animal but did not
physically change form
in the 13th century collection saga of
the vulsans werewolves appear multiple
times in one story a princess named
cigne marries a rival king who in war
kills her father and captures her ten
brothers
one by one the brothers are eaten by a
large mysterious she-wolf
this happens every night until only one
sigmund is left
with the sister's help in a little honey
sigmund kills the wolf believed to be a
human woman in disguise by biting off
her tongue
the now dead creature is believed to be
sydney's mother-in-law who had taken on
a wolf form through witchcraft in
another example from the saga a thieving
father and son duo find two magic wolf
pelts in a forest hut they put on the
skins transform into wolves and are
horrified to learn they cannot transform
back
unbeknownst to them the skins can only
be removed every 10 days in wolf form
they decide to separate but if they meet
too much trouble on their own they
should howl for help
the son ignores this warning and manages
to kill 11 men before severely injuring
himself
after the 10 days pass both men returned
to human form
horrified by the experience they burned
the magic pelts as thieves the two live
separated from society embodying wolfish
tendencies before turning into literal
wolves
in the norse language the word for wolf
is vag since wolves were considered
withdrawn and solitary varg inspired the
word vargur which roughly translates to
outlaw while some etymologists argue
that the where in werewolf comes from
the anglo-saxon word for man others
claim that extra e and the common
variations of war and vagr challenge
this idea
one thing that does seem clear is that
from the beginning of their infamous
name werewolves have been associated
with solitude and violence
in terms of the word werewolf the
etymology itself is somewhat complicated
and not always clear it said that it
could come from the old english or from
the old german or from a mixture of two
what does seem to be clear is that it
specifically refers to the word man
wolf and by man i don't mean how we use
the term man today meaning mankind but
rather masculine or male the male or
masculine human and so werewolf
necessarily means a male monster and
this certainly has been the case that we
do find that there are definitely more
male werewolves than there are female
werewolves their germanic nordic
traditions spread across europe as its
people did and that's why werewolf
stories are found in indigenous
icelandic sources it's also likely that
celtic werewolf stories were likewise
influenced by the ancient nordic people
especially given that the strongest
werewolf tradition comes from ossary an
area with strong historical ties to
vikings as the werewolf legend spread
different cultures and geographic areas
contributed their own unique flourishes
resulting in a staggering number of
werewolf variations
serbian legend says one becomes a
werewolf if you drink water from the
footprint of a wolf danish tradition
dictates that only danish men can become
werewolves
russian folk believe claims that a witch
placing her girdle under a house
threshold on the inhabitants wedding day
will turn all who are celebrating into
wolves once they cross over it the
introduction of christianity saw these
ancient beliefs and myths rewritten as
pagan and therefore sinful so the
werewolf became something to be
disproved and denied through mental
illness or demonic influence
human to wolf transformation would be a
defiance of divinity only god had the
power to alter something so completely
the first recorded use of the word
werewolf appears in the 11th century in
the ecclesiastical ordinances of king
knut where it is used symbolically to
warn christian clergy to be on the
lookout for those who might threaten
their congregation the differences and
similarities in european werewolves
under christianity reflect the dominant
anxieties and values of europe during
the middle ages
one such example emerged in the
recurring trope of the sympathetic
werewolf where a human soul trapped in a
wolf body could be divinely saved if
they shown their devotion to god celtic
traditions of werewolves from the time
developed to shape the creature into
victims suffering from involuntary
transformation a sympathetic
interpretation that reflects the heavy
influence of christianity in the country
as illustrated in archdeacon and
historian gerald of wales account of the
landscape and people of ireland
published in the late 12th century
topographia hibernica narrates an
encounter between a priest and a
werewolf where the monster asks the holy
man for communion and last rites for his
wife who is also a werewolf a fact that
is revealed when the desperate male
werewolf pulls back her wolf skin to
reveal an elderly woman perhaps the
singular most important sympathetic
werewolf tale of the 12th century is
located in marie de france's biscrive
published in the latter part of the
century the french poem of a werewolf
night was translated into old norse
broadening its readership
the story focuses on a handsome happily
married noble knight who just so happens
to disappear from home every three days
his wife accuses him of having an affair
and he won't defend his absence saying
the truth will only harm her
the wife asks him again and again for an
explanation until finally he says my
lady i turn biss clavre i plunge into
that great forest in thick woods i like
it best i live on what prey i can get
he's naked when this happens and will
not tell her where he hides his clothes
because if they are lost he could stay a
werewolf forever
after a bit of nagging he reveals they
are under a bush at an old chapel the
terrified wife devises a plan to escape
the marriage she and her lover steal her
husband's clothes and when he never
returns home the lovers marry
a year later the missing husband's
friend the king is hunting in their
woods when he comes across biscarve in
werewolf form
instead of killing the beast the king
spares his life after the wolf shows his
human side kissing his foot and leg
the werewolf joins the king's retinue
and is well cared for
all is well until biscriva's wife's new
husband attends the king's feast and the
werewolf bites the knight and drags him
away although the king manages to stop
him from killing the man
biscuit is violent again when the king's
hunting party comes across his scheming
wife and he attacks the woman tearing
off her nose and face
he's about to be killed when a wise
fellow proposes that his violence
against these two people shows he has a
great grudge and speculates the beast is
the missing knight
under the king's questioning in pain and
fear the lady confesses to stealing the
clothing the king demands its return but
this clave ignores the clothes too
ashamed to show the terrible change from
the form of a beast only when he is
alone does bisgrave dawn the clothes
turning back to human form
the lady in her night are expelled from
the realm and in an interesting
extension of the werewolves curse some
of their female progeny are born without
noses other european werewolf traditions
grew as well the sympathetic werewolf
was joined by the werewolf lover in
these tales a woman is attacked by a
wolf who rips off some of her clothes
usually her apron or skirt
later when he returns in human form the
woman recognizes him as the werewolf by
the clothing or threads between his
teeth scholars often read these stories
as symbolic of sexual assault against
women there is also the wounded werewolf
a trope where the male human form of the
werewolf is only revealed when the beast
is struck by a knife or piece of wood
now that his human identity is revealed
he is no longer a threat then there are
the back rider or wolf rider stories
where a man transforms into a werewolf
with the help of a special belt or skin
these werewolves would cling to the back
of a male victim
during the middle ages werewolf legends
evolved and expanded becoming more
widespread and more demonized by the
church
reports of werewolf activity increased
now barry lopez in his book of wolves of
men suggest that one of the reasons why
the way that the werewolf was changing
in terms of depiction was in part
because of the way wolves were being
seen
in the 1400s in europe farming was
changing and it was becoming more um
about sheep and sheep became a center of
the economy within europe now
unfortunately not only did humans like
she but so did wolves and suddenly there
was a sense that wolves were predating
that walls were destroying expensive
sheep and
were a threat to livelihood and to
economy
and because of this and because of the
pre-existing symbolism within uh
religion within christianity regarding
the wolf
and
sheep as god's flock
it quite nicely fitted in together that
the wolf became seen as more monstrous
and monstrous and therefore the werewolf
became seen as more and more monstrous
and that a transformation into the wolf
was necessarily an evil thing most
likely caused by the enemy of god the
devil as werewolf stories continued to
rise in popularity the church's stance
on the creature changed where before it
was an official sin in the christian
church two believe in werewolves because
it suggested that beings other than god
could alter physical substance beginning
in the later 16th century it was
considered heretical to not believe in
werewolves a change that came after the
church shifted its attention to
persecuting witches and this change
seems to be an attempt again to deal
with the proliferation of werewolves but
also to deal with the fact that the
belief and the myth of wells doesn't
seem to be going anywhere until it made
more sense to suggest that the devil
literally could transform man into wolf
and i think this is because the church
saw that it was far better to keep
responding and adapting and absorbing
these beliefs rather than absolutely
refuting them shape-changing into wolves
became a component in witchcraft
accusations and was often accompanied by
charges of cannibalism part of the rise
of the so-called werewolf trials is also
due to a seminal text on identifying and
punishing witches the malleus
maleficarum
co-authored by catholic clergymen and
inquisitors heinrich kramer and johann
springer after its publication in 1486
this legal and theological text not only
became the standard for witch hunting it
served as a handbook for the approved
torture of those accused the texts
claimed some witches were able to turn
into wolves although this metamorphosis
was an illusion rather than a true
transformation
it was the devil who helped produce
glamours a kind of magic that makes
things appear different from their true
form in this case making someone appear
as a wolf
this werewolf glamour increased strength
speed and intelligence all advantages to
help them kill and eat humans
medieval christian demonologists also
believe the devil would appear in the
form of a wolf
the rising christian doctrine condemning
witchcraft is only one factor as to why
cannibalistic werewolf accusations rose
the black death of their bubonic plague
is another by the end of the 14th
century it is estimated that anywhere
from 20 to 75 percent of the global
population succumbed to the black death
fewer people meant less encroachment on
the wolves natural habitat and therefore
the wolf population grew
in the 15th and 16th centuries reports
of roving wolf packs increased they ate
livestock and occasionally attacked
humans which corresponded to an increase
in werewolf accusations throughout
europe
in france belief in werewolves or in the
lu garu men destined to become wolves at
the full moon were at an all-time high
during the inquisition with 30 000
reported cases between 1520 and 1630 not
surprising giving the aim to combat
heresy in canada the indigenous legends
of wolves and shapeshifters were
confronted with french folklore often in
expressions attempting to oppress
indigenous spiritual practices with
christian ideology
the myths and the ideas regarding
werewolves and wolves would travel to
the new world with the settlers and
colonizers who came from europe these
creatures that we had thought we had
destroyed or left behind in many ways
therefore the landscape seemed to be a
landscape of nightmares now the
colonizers made use in some ways of
these pre-existing myths it gave a
function for why wolves had to be
destroyed
unfortunately the hatred of wolves would
be misapplied as well to the indigenous
population and so
the way that wolves are seen as savage
and voracious creatures was used in
intimately racist and violent terms
against the native americans themselves
werewolf trials in central and western
europe peaked in the early 17th century
and the label werewolf could be applied
to someone who engaged in heinous crimes
outside of witchcraft like murder
cannibalism and rape
in many cases the shape-shifting was
less significant than the murder and
cannibalism associated with the change
in fact during the 16th century many of
the werewolf executions reported by the
catholic church involved confessions of
eating human flesh particularly that of
children no 16th century werewolf gained
more notoriety than german farmer peter
stoob it was said he made a deal with
the devil that allowed him to take the
shape of a wolf in order to kill men
women and children without getting
caught for over 25 years
steub was captured by a group of hunters
looking for the beast that had been
slaughtering their families in livestock
their dogs succeeded in chasing down a
wolf but the hunters lost sight of it
only to see stoob in the same spot the
wolf had vanished the hunters assumed he
had removed his werewolf girdle and
regained his human form
after a little torture on the rack he
quickly confessed to procuring the
girdle becoming a wolf and murdering 14
children and two pregnant women he
reportedly killed his own son and ate
his brain committed incest with his
daughter and sister and was rumored to
have had a long affair with a she-devil
sent to him by satan
his daughter and mistress were also
tried and found guilty as accessories to
the murders and on october 31st 1589
they were all executed stoop was laid on
a wheel and burning pincers were used to
pull the flesh off his body his legs and
arms were broken and his head was
removed the body burned to ash
his daughter and mistress were burned to
death with his corpse
stew's severed head was spiked on a pole
and displayed below a wooden carving of
a wolf the cruelty of the crimes and
punishment were immortalized in 1590 as
an english narrative a true discourse
declaring the damnable life and death of
one student peter the first popular
werewolf narrative in england that
reinvigorated great britain's interest
in the monster after it had all but been
eradicated in the previous few centuries
after aggressive wolf cleansing
campaigns the stub case and others like
it are today recognized by many scholars
as evidence of early human serial
killers rather than supernatural
werewolves
this reflects a movement that began
hundreds of years before as history
attempted to rationalize or explain the
actions of those who claim to be wolf
shapeshifters while today there is a
distinction between the fictional
werewolf and the condition of
lycanthropy the two ideas were entwined
for most of history as early as the
second century and well into the 18th
century lycanthropy could refer to both
the literal transformation of human to
wolf using magic
and to a form of mental illness where a
person believed they could become a wolf
today physicians recognize clinical
lycanthropy or lycomania as a real
disorder a rare condition where patients
believe they are transforming into or
have transformed into a non-human animal
another explanation behind werewolves is
a hallucination brought on by drugs
archaeological and literary evidence
suggests that the trance that endowed
the berserkers with supposed increased
strength and speed may have been caused
by the ingestion of hallucinogenic
mushrooms another commonly cited
hallucinogen that may have contributed
to werewolf delusions is outbreaks of
ergot poisoning the fungus can infect
rye wheat barley and oats common food
sources and when ingested causes
hallucinations and physical symptoms
like uncontrollable body movements panic
attacks a burning sensation and gangrene
still historical evidence suggests that
even hundreds of years ago it would have
been hard to unintentionally digest er
got poisoned food and blaming werewolves
on hallucinations alone doesn't hold up
yet another proposed medical explanation
for werewolf lore is congenital
generalized hypertrichosis terminolus
also called werewolf syndrome or ombro
syndrome the disease causes extreme hair
growth that often covers the entire body
documented since the 17th century it is
a recognized condition today believed to
be caused by gene mutation
an excess of hair in unusual places was
often cited as evidence of a werewolf in
their human form so some accused
werewolves may have just been suffering
from this condition then in the 20th
century two new explanations appeared
porphyria and rabies porphyria is a rare
genetic disease characterized by severe
photosensitivity that results in some
stereotypical werewolf traits
hyperpigmentation excessive hair growth
nocturnal wandering and red or reddish
brown teeth the rabies virus causes
crazed and frenzied behavior in animals
including wolves who are driven to more
aggressive behavior when the virus
attacks the brain often against other
animals and even humans
in humans symptoms include difficulty
swallowing increased thirst inflammation
of the brain hypersexuality irrational
fear of water contraction of the lips
and although extremely rare the desire
to bite other humans i can't count the
number of times that people have
explained to me that the reason why
anyone has ever believed in werewolves
is because of porphyria or ergot
poisoning or hyper hirsutism
and i find this a really flawed way of
thinking about werewolves and monsters
more generally i think trying to explain
away beliefs actually destroys the power
and the wonder of the supernatural and
also the symbolism and importance of
monsters so i think really it's far
better to allow werewolves to remain a
creature that can be interpreted in a
multiplicity of different ways and for
us to understand that werewolves wolves
and other monsters remain powerful
symbols within the human imagination the
proposed explanations for werewolves
aren't quite as numerous as the
different variations of this monster but
they indicate a desire to understand
strange and deviant behavior given that
wolves were at one point the most common
and dangerous land-based predators in
europe and did pose an immediate threat
to humans their connection to witchcraft
and werewolves other perceived threats
to humanity isn't all that surprising
fear of the werewolf in the medieval and
early modern period seems to be about
the possibility that the body is
malleable the mental capacity to shed
one's identity so dramatically into
another body or persona that seems more
monstrous violent and unpredictable
may have helped us explain the crimes
humanity can commit against one another
the werewolf is one of the most
well-known monsters we've covered on
monstrum and one that has endured for
centuries
but why
in part two of the series we'll cover
how the werewolf has continued to claw
at our modern imaginations contributed
to werewolf delusions is air
herb breaks
of air got poisoning urgot
outbreaks of ergot